oui alors vous êtes fou d'aller sur
internet c'est le titre de votre livre
en même temps à l'heure où même mon
réfrigérateur est connecté comment
voulez vous que l'on se passe d'internet
c'est impossible aujourd'hui
vous avez raison et donc la raison quand
il faut faire il faut avoir conscience
des risques de l'internet dans le livre
je recense les 100 piège pour pouvoir
quelque part les anticiper voilà si
demain vous ai pas envie alors là vous
parlez des frigos j'ai pas un tête un
risque lié à un frigo mais quand vous
recevez sur votre ordinateur une arnaque
on vous fait peur on vous demande de
payer les 500 euros sinon on divulgue
vos vidéos prétendument où vous avez été
sur des sites olé olé oui mais ça tombe
bien il est très très très très sur ce
site là pas trop donc il faut avoir
conscience de ces risques pour pouvoir
les éviter et les anticiper d'accord
très bien emilie alors moi je pars du
principe que quand on accepte d'aller
sur internet on accepte aussi être un
petit peu espionner du coup je vous
avoue j'ai pas hyper peur sur internet
quel est le danger principal de quoi
comment convaincre qu'il faut que je la
vois rappelé est honneur d'être un peu
prudentes alors fait un test si vous
pensez que vous n'avez pas d'intimité à
avoir sur internet c'est que vous ne
donnez votre téléphone portable vous
ouvrez les codes et je vais lire vos sms
vos mails si vous n'avez pas sur les
photos savard on voit la photo vous
allez voir ah oui mais là cette personne
je la connais pas et là vous commencez à
avoir une sensation au niveau de votre
intimité qui commence ça fait moins la
maligne la halle à l'opel alors ouais
d'accord
effectivement c'est un bon exemple pour
se dire c'est parce que je connais
beaucoup à pas par emilie lopez bien sûr
je connais beaucoup de jeunes notamment
qui disent de toute façon c'est la règle
du jeu ça va on ouvre donc des espionnes
ou flic un peu c'est pas très grave mais
ce moyen là de se dire tu accordes moi
ton téléphone
on va voir si tout et n'importe qui
peuvent peuvent lire ton l'intégralité
des t2t donner car ben oui j'aimerais
bien qu'on parle des jeunes parce que
c'est vrai que ça arrive que les jeunes
voient la face des rencontres sur
internet ils peuvent s'échanger des
choses des photos dénudées plus ou moins
et c est effectivement ensuite ils
peuvent être victimes de chantage
comment on fait quand on est parent pour
protéger ses enfants de ça sans être
trop intrusif
alors ça ça le vrai sujet il peut y
avoir des drames et puis avoir des
drames parce que l'enfant culpabiliser
il a fait
il la voyait une photo dénudée où il a
fait plus via via internet et souvent
l'adolescent peut être coupé
relationnellement avec ses parents donc
il est isolé et là ce qu'il faut faire
c'est anticiper
il faut lui expliquer que cela peut
arriver que c'est pas grave il ya des
solutions qui existent aujourd'hui
et voilà moi c'est ce que je propose
c'est de prendre le temps d'aller lui en
parler et il m'expliquait que même si on
passe quand on imagine toujours en tout
cas les adolescents en tout cas 10 bat
partie moment où cette photo circule on
ne pourra plus jamais là bloqué avec moi
poursuit toute ma vie on tolère les
rassurer oui on peut les rassurer
aujourd'hui il ya des solutions on n'est
plus comme il ya quelques années il ya
cinq ans ou quand on demandé à youtube
au houga fans de la série de
plates-formes supprimer des données nous
sommes été un temps infini aujourd'hui
c'est beaucoup plus rapide et le
gouvernement est en train de faire
pression une mettre en place des
systèmes pour que les gaffes à
réagissent encore plus vite
voilà dites-nous juste les solutions
concrètes à la portée de tous pour être
en sécurité sur internet mais dans
l'utilisation classique de tous les
jours d'internet c'est-à-dire ne me
dites pas de ne pas aller sur google.fr
parce que là c'est retourner au
moyen-âge et perso je peux pas moi
j'invite tout le monde à faire un usage
massif d'internet
moi je me force pas la même a de temps
en temps à aller sur des applications
que je ne connais pas pour rester à la
page
parce que je pense que sinon ça va créer
un décalage et mes enfants donc je fais
des forges que même des efforts sur les
jeux vidéo et donc les conseils
pratiques sur pour boucler avec le cyber
harcèlement c'est de préserver un petit
peu son anonymat notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux et une astuce très
pratique dont on imagine qu'il faut pas
mettre son nom son prénom son lieu
professionnel pour les adultes ou son
lieu de domicile
mais une chose à laquelle on ne pense
pas c'est la photo c'est à dire que des
fois vous mettez une photo anonyme mais
vous vous rendez pas compte que cette
même photo vous l'avez publié par
ailleurs et là sur une application sur
lequel on sait remonter à votre identité
il existe des applications ou à partir
de la photo de profil on va rebondir à
retrouver toutes les sources qui ont
publié cette photo
donc ça s'appelle m c'est un simple
paysage exactement veut remonter en dix
ans mais ça ça a été publié sur un
compte qui lui n'était plus anonymes
comme un facebook par les actes eux mans
et on va coupler les deux photos en fait
celle qui parlait ou celui qui parlait
c'était dire que ce paysage n'a été
publié que par valérie donc remonter
avec dakar très bien ça c'est quelque
chose de très concret et pour terminer
vous parliez aussi d'usurpation
d'identité est ce qu'on peut se prémunir
de ça parce qu'effectivement quand on va
faire un achat par exemple sur un e-shop
monde donne sa carte bleue on donne des
informations sur notre de naissance
enfin et sur le lieu de résidence etc et
a presque cessé propre et ça ne mesure
pas son identité comment pour faire pour
bloquer ça alors là il ya une astuce
assez simple c'est qu'il faut éviter de
diffuser ces cartes d'identité sur
internet
même si bon des fois quand on vous le
demande il faut limiter à tout prix cela
et quand vous êtes obligés de le faire
de diffuser sur internet votre carte
d'identité
vous prenez vous êtes une photocopie
évidemment vous envoyer une photocopie
si possible un petit peu dégradée et
vous barrer au stabilo en disant c'est
envoyer tes jours à telle personne pour
tel usage très bien avait servi vrai
astuces parce que qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire avec ça c'est que des personnes
vont aller prendre des crédits à votre
nom si vous retrouvez à rembourser des
crédits que vous n'avez pas pris sic m
un petit peu gênant